[Music]
we are at war with russia
or perhaps more correctly we have lost a
war with russia without a battle
we are no longer a sovereign nation we
are no longer a democracy we are no
longer a free people
we are the victims of a bloodless coup
so far a bloodless coup
engineered by russia with at best the
traitorous indifference of the
republican party
and donald john trump a man who to
borrow a phrase from another december
long ago
will live in infamy in five weeks time
unless desperate measures are taken we
will hand over the government to a man
who lost the popular vote
by more than woodrow wilson or jimmy
carter won it
a man whom the russians wanted to run
our country for them a man who the
russians got
to run our country for them a man for
whom the russians interfered with our
elections
which if we did it to another country
would be described as an
act of war and in this country we have
conceded defeat
some experts john kasich's strategist
john weaver for one have compared this
to pearl harbor
even the hard right x congressman joe
walsh says republican silence
will be tantamount to treason some
others too have proved courageous
trump self-destructive to the last
issued a childish statement mocking the
cia
but as tim dickinson of rolling stone
noted not denying anything
but the vast majority of republicans
have said nothing
and the vast majority of democrats have
said nothing and the vast majority of
the media has said nothing of substance
and the president has said nothing close
to enough
the cia and fbi and homeland security
the institutions whose interest in
freedom we on the left
most frequently distrust they have said
something
they said it first to congressional and
senate republicans in
september dire warnings warnings that
mitch mcconnell and other republicans
reportedly buried
warnings that the russians using
computer hacking and perhaps
other means were not merely trying to
discredit the election
but to achieve the specific outcome of
electing their
man trump and finally at the very last
hour
some of those who did those briefings
and some of those who received those
briefings
leaked the details to the new york times
the washington post cbs news reuters
in a torrent of anguished honesty they
said something
they said something as the president not
elect
began to veer towards appointing as
secretary of state
as our diplomatic face to the world the
ceo of
exxon who four years ago received the
order of friendship
from vladimir putin they said something
as the members of the electoral college
prepared to gather next monday to
finalize this
coup some perhaps unaware that almost
half the states they represent permit
them by law
to vote for someone other than the
candidate to whom they are pledged
and that only 38 of them need to do so
to prevent this coup
they said something as one especially
chilling detail in one of the reports
sailed by that quote the russians
hacked the republican national
committee's computer systems in addition
to their attacks on democratic
organizations
but did not release whatever information
they gleaned from the republican
networks
it is a short leap from that conclusion
and it is anything but a conspiracy
theory to be wondering if the russians
hacked the rnc and have kept what they
found there
to make sure trump and the republicans
obeyed
the president of the united states who
at this rate will be the last
freely elected president of the united
states made in his measured way a small
gesture last friday
that perhaps opened the door to these
horrifying revelations of a coup by an
outside power
nearly complete he asked for a full
review
but we do not have time for a full
review barack obama has twice stood in
front of america in front of the world
in front of history and said
i do solemnly swear that i will
faithfully execute the office
of president of the united states and
will to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend the
constitution of the united states
today is the time for him to do so
he must immediately declassify and
release
all relevant materials held by the fbi
the cia
dhs and the other intelligence and
security services and in the white house
and anywhere else in government and the
attorney general must immediately
appoint a special prosecutor
to investigate what donald trump knew
and when he knew it
and what if any collusive links exist
now or existed earlier between the
russian federation
and the republican national committee if
trump does grab
power he can try to dismiss that special
prosecutor but he will at least have to
get the courts
to sanction him and most immediately
the intelligence briefing proposed today
for the electoral college
what the cia and the others know when
they knew it how much the trump campaign
knew
that must be conducted without delay and
without redactions
there are no arguments of security or
face saving or intelligence secrecy or
national interest that carry any weight
now
how much worse can it get by telling
america the unvarnished
unprocessed unredacted truth about this
coup
we are already on the precipice of
losing the freedom
and independence of the nation he must
tell us so that we
may defend ourselves he must tell the
electors of the electoral college so
that microscopic has the chance may be
they could still prevent this cataclysm
there is no time for a full review
or a measured analysis or
recommendations to prevent
interference in our future elections
because permitting donald trump to
assume the office of president
reduces the chance that we will have any
future elections
the nation and all of our freedoms hang
by a thread
and the military apparatus of this
country is about to be handed over to
scum
who are beholden to scum russian
scum as things are today january 20th
will not be an inauguration
but rather the end of the united states
as an independent country
it will not be a peaceful change of
power it will be a usurpation
and the usurper has no validity no
credibility
and no authority under the constitution
this is a reality that will become the
only reality until this country
rids itself of donald john trump he is
not
a president he is a puppet put in power
by vladimir putin
and those who ignore these elemental
existential facts
democrats or republicans are traitors
to this country and will immediately and
forever after
be held accountable resist
peace